all right hello Benjamin
um you caught more calmly go by just Ben
right do you have a preference uh but
both are both are fine with me okay well
actually I do go a little bit more by
Benjamin you know I'm not I'm not from
the US
so you're telling me that in the
Netherlands they don't call you with
shorter names they just call you by your
full name
yeah well the thing is for example with
people call Ben Feingold they call him
Ben Feingold right but I'm assuming his
first name's just Ben right like it it's
his name Benjamin Feingold
his name is Benjamin fine oh I never
knew yeah there so that's that that's
really the difference like in the US
people's name like if someone's name is
Ben His official name is actually
Benjamin but he just goes by Ben okay
right whereas for me it's like you can
call me
Ben is more like a nickname uh-huh yeah
but I don't want to go by Ben Bach that
sounds a lot worse than Benjamin Bach
not going to lie yeah okay so that's why
you know just just do Benjamin all right
Benjamin sounds good okay well it's
great to have you here Benjamin
um I know that you're going to be on the
archbishops I'm really excited to be the
captain and I'm sure you're really
excited to be representing them once
again I heard that the first time you
played for the archbishops was in 2019.
did you play every year after that how
has that been for you
yeah so I made my debut for St Louis
archbishops in 2019 and actually we went
to the live finals which was an awesome
experience and we won that one and in
2020 I I was also on a team and we I
believe yeah we ended up winning but it
went offline the the finals who played
offline oh and yeah 2021 I was also on a
team we came second I believe and I
don't think there was a leak in 2022 so
this year we're looking to take it all
again that's amazing how are you how do
you feel with your team and everything
your team looks super strong you have
world number
okay honestly I don't know what number
Fabiano Carana is right now I have
five-ish five-ish okay world you know
number five on the team obviously he's a
legend how do you feel with your current
roster it looks quite strong
yeah no we have an amazing team we have
Fabiano caruana like you said one of the
best players in the world he has also
really stepped up his game in Rapid
chess recently we also have Dominguez
also an extremely strong Grandmaster
Jeffrey Zhang who's around 2700 but I
think in Rapid Jeffrey is a Little Bit
Stronger he's in the in uh last year's
rapid Chess Championship he was really
hanging with the best and also
um in the what's it called the chesacom
global Championship he did uh pretty
well but also I think players like
Nicolas theodoro he's definitely way
underrated in especially in Rapid chess
he he's extremely good so I definitely
expect a lot from him and yeah we also
have strong female players so I I also
have faith in them that they have been
stepping up their game in uh leading up
to the season so I think we have a
pretty good chance yeah I mean the team
roster just looks super strong your
female player you have like two women
Grandmasters years you know I I've I've
seen amazing things from all of the
players on your team
I do understand that
um sorry let me rephrase this
um I do understand that the archbishops
are have won before
do you think you guys will be making it
into the final four this year do you
think you'll be making it to the finals
what what how far do you expect to go
yeah I do expect us to go deep I don't
know exactly what the path will be to
the finals and I think it will also
depend who we who we will meet on our
way
but I think one of our biggest Rivals
are gonna be the Canada chess bras they
have Magnus on their team Magnus will
count as a 2700 but he's actually 28.50
so they gain a lot of value there
besides that I think also the Gotham
Knights will be really good with Hikaru
and one other player I saw on their team
who will be someone to look out for is
Michael and Norby Bortnick because he's
only like 2440 but on chestercom he's
like 29.50 blitz so he's way underrated
as well
so I guess since we're a North American
team we might we we might meet those
teams on our way to the finals so it
will definitely not be an easy path but
I I do like our chances yeah absolutely
I mean there are some really really
strong players this year will you
mentioned the Canadian Canada chess bra
sorry they don't just have magnets
Carlson they also have Anish giri who is
27.64 and Jordan man forest and numerous
other really really strong players how
do you feel about Magnus Carlson also
being in the PCL this year
yeah I think it's awesome that the
approach wrestling now really sees the
best players in the world we have Magnus
Carlson we have Nakamura Fabiana corvana
and I think that's really what the
league needs to be more accessible to to
viewers from all over the world I think
they they try to change the format a
couple years ago where they LED teams
stack their teams as as much as possible
with no raiding cap but I think that
concept didn't really work out because
some the
the competition became a little bit
lopsided with certain teams like
ourselves having just the best players
in the world and other teams couldn't
really compete so I think they got a
nice format where they will have the
best players in the world compete but
where also every team will have a chance
so I'm very excited like chess has grown
a lot in recent years anything you know
with Magnus playing with Hikaru with
Fabiano the the protest league is just
gonna be awesome for friends to watch
absolutely I mean the protest League I I
remember watching it you know in 2019 it
was really really exciting so now with
the whole chess boom like three times
chest boom whatever it is at this point
you know I feel like a lot of people are
going to be tuning in this is going to
be a really large event incorporating
all of the world top players
it is going to be a ten plus two format
which means 10 minutes two second
increment for viewers
um are you more confident playing
against higher rated players in Rapid or
you know in classical
yeah so I don't play a whole lot of
classical anymore
um I yeah I mainly play Blitz online but
I do like playing rapid
I think it's just a little bit more
relaxed like you you just you just play
your game there's not too much to think
about
so I yeah I like I like playing rapid I
I think there's a nice mixture between
you know still playing fast and you know
just enjoying the game but you also do
have to think so
I I like I like my chances in in Rapid
and and like I said I think we also have
a couple other rapid Specialists on our
team yeah that's awesome to hear I mean
honestly I think
I haven't played a lot of classical in
the last couple of years mostly out of
choice
um and I have to admit rapid is a lot
more fun than playing classical so it's
going to be exciting the games are going
to be much faster paced and I think it's
in the format especially that you guys
are playing which is
um Everybody Plays
everybody wants correct
so it would be yeah
yeah so you will be playing against
everybody on the enemy team which is you
know pretty intense
um so that should be a lot of fun and it
should help the whole event run a look a
little faster
so these are going to be more of the fun
questions
um I appreciate you sharing your
thoughts about the archbishops and the
PCL in general
what do you view as your own like best
achievement in chess
yeah so in in 2015 I won the London uh
London fitted open uh I won the London
chess classic video open so that was my
biggest tournament Victory but I would
say for myself making it to the World
Cup in 2019 and reaching the round of
64. probably is sort of the the height
of my career so to speak in my over the
board in my overboard career because
that's sort of the the deepest I've gone
in the in the world championship cycle
but apart from that last year I reached
the round of 32 in the cheslaco global
Championship which is almost like an
online World Cup and I actually defeated
Alexander grishek in the round of 64 so
I guess it's those those three uh
achievements really that that's
um I did check Wikipedia obviously and I
found out that you defeated Yvonne sarik
in the first round for the chess uh for
the World Cup in 2019 and then you were
eliminated by Alexander gristook in the
second round so I'm sure it must have
felt you know
a bit of Revenge and everything what not
when you defeated him in the global
chess championships
yeah I know for sure when I played him
in the World Cup in 2019 it was actually
it was also around the same time both
matches were played in in September and
I think it was just like three days off
it was exactly three years ago so I
definitely had that feeling of Revenge
because at the World Cup in 2019 I
actually did have chances to beat him
because we drew our two classical games
and in the first rapid game I I should
have won the one it ended in the draw
and then I lost the second game yeah I
mean the World Cup is just such a tough
format because he only played two rounds
were you happier playing in the global
championships where the format was a
little longer
it doesn't really make a big difference
I think either way the mattress are just
super close and I had a similar feeling
like I felt against Grisha you know the
match we made four draws in the in the
regular games and it did feel like those
games were definitely tough like had I
lost the game I don't know if I would
have been able to to come back so I
wasn't a way happy to make it to an
Armageddon and I thought okay either way
if I have the black pieces I'll just you
know fight for a draw but if I'll play
with white piece I'm just gonna you know
throw everything at him I'm just gonna
go all out and I'm gonna try to win and
yeah happily luckily it worked out the
classical chess strategy this is what
all the grand Masters do by the way you
have to hold your draws as black and
then go for the win as white that's
that's that's the secret all right so
you've been at St Louis for a couple of
years now and you recently graduated
from Europe uh with your bachelor's
and that's correct in finance Finance
okay and now you're doing your masters
yep that's correct and you've been have
you been on the chess team this entire
time for the last four years or so
uh yes I've been on the protest like
team since 2019 so that was in my first
year at SLU and uh yeah of course when I
came to slow I was also playing for the
salute chess team I mean that's part of
my scholarship right and what is your
favorite class at Slough
actually I'm taking a class right now in
blockchain and it's probably one of the
first classes that I find really
interesting so that one is definitely
cool so are you for or against crypto
what what are your thoughts on
cryptocurrencies
uh
well it remains to be seen but I think
it's definitely it's definitely
interesting so you know if you if yeah
it's definitely interesting yeah I think
the usage of blockchain is super
interesting obviously we don't need to
get much very deep into it but um when I
was doing my own undergrad at University
of Toronto which I did not finish
uh yeah blockchains and just all of that
kind of like stuff was really big
because of uh my statistics major so
yeah did like a deep dive into that too
so that's really really cool
do you have any Ambitions for after slew
do you have any Ambitions for you know
whenever you do graduate or if you
choose to put it on hold are you
thinking about going more into content
question I I do want to try to grow my
my twitch and YouTube channels but it's
of course not easy so right now I'm also
working on a couple other things I'm
working on a course for chessful that I
hope to get out really soon and yeah I
uh hopefully that'll be successful and
if it will I might make more courses in
the future
uh besides that yeah
um
yeah I think that that will be my main
focus for now and I might get more into
to coaching because it's a bit more of a
stable it's a bit more stable than
creating content right
do you have a favorite kind of content
to create
I like creating I guess educational
content where your viewers can really
benefit from
besides that yeah there's nothing really
that that comes to mind right away yeah
what's your
um what's the chessful course going to
be on are you allowed to reveal that
it's gonna be an opening but I I want to
keep it a secret okay
of course now I'm really excited to
check that out I mean chessable has been
great and you know I think you would be
an amazing coach on chessful and an
amazing coach in general which once
again you have been doing a lot of
educational content we've seen you
um commentate on hikaru's channel seen
you commentating on I believe I've also
seen you commentate on the official
chess.com channels right
Channel and it's always it's always a
lot of fun because even when I'm not
commentating I I'm gonna watch the games
regardless
on the front row so to speak yeah how
much time do you spend on your chest on
a daily basis do you if you do
right so right now that I'm working on
adjustable course it's actually quite a
lot because of course I have to study an
opening seriously so I don't know how to
quantify it in hours but
to be fair in recent years not as much I
would say when I played in the World Cup
in 2019 obviously I did a lot of
preparation for that and for the World
Cup I also played in 2021 and the
Olympiad in 2022 but if I don't really
have a big tournament coming up I I
don't spend that much time
on on chess but uh yeah when I have
Victor coming up it's easily like six
six hours or maybe even wow that's a lot
of time yeah
yeah it gets pretty intense but I mean
my colleagues do the same so I have to
try to keep up right so on top of your
studies at SLU you also have to do
additional chest studying because you're
part of the slow chesty
that that seems like a very difficult
you know work life
balance sort of thing
yeah it sure is I mean yeah besides
being a student I'm also you know a
transcript master so I have to you know
study chess to to Keep On My Level uh
and yeah besides that I'm also you know
a content creator or streamer so that
takes time
so yeah I try to just put in as many
hours as possible
yeah yeah that's it yeah it definitely
sounds like a lot of work but thank you
very much really appreciate having you
on this interview
and I hope the best for your chess games
I'll definitely be watching and we'll be
cheering you on
yeah thanks Nema it's a pleasure being
here and yeah up to a good season